c'est une vraie honte il y a pas de
glace pour glacer les patients il y a
rien du tout et vous venez quel jour
après
on a eu aujourd'hui très chaud dans
toute la France dans la moitié nord les
températures on varier entre 32 et 35
degrés dans le sud de mercure a atteint
des pics à 39 degrés résultat la chaleur
persistante et l'absence de vent ont
provoqué des pics de pollution à l'ozone
dans plusieurs régions notamment en
Île-de-France en Lorraine en Provence et
en Rhône-Alpes et dans les prochains
jours ça ne devrait pas s'arranger si on
en croit Météo France le point avec
emiliane Stein
un petit coin de tranquillité ici
bienvenue sur la plage du Ning au bord
du Rhin même les signes ne s'y sont pas
trompés grâce à la station d'épuration
non loin l'eau est on ne peut plus
propre super super propre super chaud de
25 degrés génial c'est le bonheur ici
je peux vous en chercher il y a plein de
coquillages là dedans non non il est
plus poli et il est propre des baigneurs
heureux donc un peu plus loin à
Strasbourg d'autres ont été moins
chanceux la piscine affiche complet
c'est dur quoi parce qu'il fait chaud et
on est là devant on attend ils disent
qu'il faut attendre une heure pour 100
personnes sortent pour que sans eux
peuvent rentrer mais bon et ce n'est pas
au bord des anciennes gravières de
Strasbourg que l'on trouvera un peu de
solitude ou de fraîcheur
pourtant je supportais soleil mais tous
les quarts d'heure je suis obligé
d'aller à l'eau pour me rafraîchir ça
devient brûlant sur le corps le
principal remède à tout cela c'est déjà
de se couvrir au maximum en mettant un
t-shirt une casquette un de la crème
indice maximum et puis surtout pour les
personnes âgées c'est d'aller faire une
petite sieste à l'ombre tranquillement
toute l'après-midi
reine de la Côte d'Azur 25 degrés dans
l'autre 39 sur la plage le mois d'août
s'annoncera Dieu et c'est tant mieux
reste que pour les campeurs les nuits
seront chaudes et conséquences directes
de la chaleur une décision insolite
d'EDF qui a décidé de placer le réacteur
nucléaire de Fessenheim en Alsace sous
un arrosage permanent il s'agit d'éviter
toute surchauffe désinstallations et
demain pas de baisse des températures
pratiquement le contraire partout le
thermomètre dépassera les 35 degrés on
prévoit de 38 à 40 dans le sud entre 41
et 43 même dans le Sud-Ouest c'est vrai
bien sûr que nous sommes en été mais
cette chaleur exceptionnelle mérite tout
de même les explications de notre
spécialiste météo fabienne amiach
record de température en France avec un
été particulièrement chaud une canicule
qui inquiète par sa durée cette vague de
chaleur est remarquable un elle-même
elle n'est pas significative du
réchauffement de la planète par contre
on constate qu'elle dure depuis la fin
du mois de mai donc ça durait alors là
est tout à fait exceptionnelle et on
constate ces dernières années une
augmentation quand même du je dirais du
des records de chaleur sur la France une
situation aggravée dans certaines
régions par une sécheresse importante le
mercure dépasse aujourd'hui dans le
Sud-Ouest plus de 40 degrés ici on voit
la moyenne des températures saisonnières
et on voit donc depuis la fin du mois de
mai on est très au-dessus des moyennes
donc on est quasiment tout le temps dans
le rouge depuis la fin du mois de mai
donc une vague de chaleur exceptionnelle
aussi par sa durée une durée qui
s'explique par la présence d'un
anticyclone puissant qui retient les
mases d'air chaud venus d'Afrique pour
cartes on voit donc l'air le plus chaud
donc qui est essentiellement centré sur
l'Espagne et une grande partie de la
France même si le Sud-Ouest est plus
particulièrement concerné je dirais que
seuls les
îles de la Manche ont des températures
fraîches et puisqu'on avait 19 degrés à
Ouessant voilà la semaine ne s'annonce
donc caniculaire avec des pics de
chaleur entre mardi et jeudi sans aucun
présage de pluie côté jardin la
température frôle 40 degrés à l'ombre à
l'intérieur de la maison de retraite
l'air est à peine plus respirable
conséquence de la canicule la
climatisation est tombée en panne alors
on ferme les stores et tout le monde est
éloigné des fenêtres
on se croirait au Sahara
il fait sûrement plus de 30 degrés et en
plus il y a pas un poil d'air il y a pas
il y a pas de courant d'air il y a pas
d'air dehors on essaye d'ouvrir les
fenêtres mais on peut pas non plus trop
les ouvrir parce qu'on commence à amène
de l'air chaud c'est un cercle vicieux
en fait la température affiche 32 degrés
5 pour les personnes âgées c'est une
épreuve au-delà d'un certain âge le
corps régule moins bien les variations
climatiques et en quelques heures elles
peuvent être déshydratées la canicule
est-elle en train de tourner au drame en
France les médecins urgentistes viennent
en tout cas de lancer un SOS il parle
d'une véritable hécatombe chez les
personnes âgées plusieurs centaines
d'entre elles seraient décédées ces
derniers jours à cause de la chaleur en
Île-de-France la fréquentation des
services d'urgence à doubler le
reportage à l'hôpital de Bobigny de
Didier brignand et Gabriel de Pommery
d'indienne les ambulances des pompiers
stationnent devant l'entrée des urgences
il fait plus de 35 degrés et ses
patients vont devoir attendre trois
heures avant d'être admis sur les
brancards des personnes âgées victimes
de déshydratation j'ai déjà fait une
personne depuis 8 ans
le personnage
et le service des urgences est proche de
l'asphyxie aux admissions il n'y a plus
de brancard disponible sur la dizaine de
personnes présentes aujourd'hui 4 sont
là pour hyperthermique d'autres pour des
problèmes respiratoires il y a aussi les
imprudences ceux qui n'ont pas assez vu
ces derniers jours victimes d'un coup de
chaud
non grande fatigue grande chaleur et
puis avec la pathologie
[Musique]
et c'est une chance lorsqu'un proche
vient d'installer un ventilateur parce
qu'ici il n'y a pas de climatisation
premier geste de l'équipe médicale
donner à boire mais en une semaine de
canicule de nombre de décès dans ce
service d'urgence a considérablement
augmenté
nous avons largement dépassé les les
idées c'est rien que sur l'hôpital
Avicenne il décède liées vraiment à la
canicule et pourtant à la veille du
week-end le nombre de lits disponibles
aux urgences a été doublé mais le
personnel médical c'est qu'avec l'été 40
% des chambres de l'hôpital sont fermées
alors si la canicule perdure le service
des urgences pourrait bien refuser des
malades et de leur côté les pompes
funèbres générales ont recensé une
hausse de 20% du nombre de morts la
semaine dernière en France 3000 au lieu
de 2500 en région parisienne il n'y a
plus de place dans les funérariums et
dans les maisons de retraite on déplore
une hausse inhabituelle du nombre de
victimes à Grigny dans l'Essonne le
reportage de Christophe Nardini et
Karine el Koubi
cette maison de retraite est une des
plus médicalisées du secteur dans
l'établissement 117 lits la moyenne
d'âge dépensionnaires et de 86 ans des
personnes en fin de vie qui ont du mal à
lutter contre les fortes températures
ici en un peu plus d'une semaine 10
personnes sont mortes de déshydratation
n'auraient pas fait plus d'ailleurs les
rares personnes que j'ai hospitalisées
avec le médecin ont été renvoyés le soir
même en disant vous faites ce qu'ils
font on peut rien faire de plus
toutes les personnes décédées avaient
plus de 80 ans et souffrait de problèmes
respiratoires et cardiaques importants
pour les infirmières le souci est
permanent il faut réhydrater désaltérer
refroidir coûte que coûte les personnes
âgées qui souvent n'ont pas le réflexe
naturel de bois
il faut oui et puis il faut s'habiller
légèrement il faut pas trop sauter faut
pas trop
il faut vivre avec le temps quoi à
l'intérieur le mercure frôle les 35
degrés l'établissement et pourtant
équipé de la climatisation mais ne peut
plus s'en servir pour des raisons de
santé publique
la climatisation avait été coupée et
demandait d'être coupé sur ce type
d'établissement il y a quelques il y a
quelques années à cause des risques de
salmonelle et autres donc on ne s'en
sert pas donc quels sont nos ressources
faire boire beaucoup tout le monde
perfuser les plus les plus atteints les
plus âgés et puis des bons brumisateurs
une situation difficile à supporter que
certains arrivent néanmoins à rendre
moins pénible auprès d'un ventilateur
oui face à l'ampleur du phénomène
l'Assistance publique d'hôpitaux de
Paris a reconnu ce soir avoir à traiter
une épidémie d'hyperthermie sans
précédent et elle a décidé d'augmenter
le nombre de lits mais pour les
urgentistes qui ont dénoncé hier soir
cette situation ça ne règle en aucun cas
le problème dans le reste du pays
Florence Trintignac et Christelle Jorion
la polémique c'est ce médecin qui l'a
lancé Patrick pelo n'hésite pas à parler
décathlonbe 50 personnes décédées ce
week-end en Île-de-France à cause de la
chaleur il dénonce la gestion de la
Direction générale de la santé qui elle
parle de mort naturelle mais qu'est-ce
qu'il foutent de la Direction générale
de la santé il se moque de qui le
problème il est bien réel c'est que nous
avons des malades qui sont en train de
mourir qui meurent peut-être plutôt que
ce qui devrait mais il n'aurait pas
d'humourir un coup de gueule entendu par
les autorités sanitaires accusées
d'avoir sous-estimé l'ampleur de la
crise résultat dès cet après-midi des
mesures sont annoncées l'Assistance
publique le confirme qu'il s'agit bien
d'une épidémie de coup de chaleur elle
craint même de nouveaux décès des deux
mains donc les hospitalisations
programmées non urgence seront reportées
certaines personnes âgées seront prises
en charge par les maisons de retraite et
surtout le nombre de lit sera augmenté
la priorité on a commencé de le dire
vendredi je le redis aujourd'hui avec
force c'est de libérer le maximum de lit
dans nos hôpitaux ça passe par quoi
premièrement c'est de trouver les moyens
de faire sortir tous les gens qui
peuvent légitimement sortir ces mesures
ne visent que la centaine
d’établissements de l'Île-de-France mais
selon l'Association des médecins
urgentistes c'est l'ensemble des
hôpitaux français qui devraient être
concernés même s'il est encore difficile
d'établir des statistiques fiables sur
le nombre de décès du à la chaleur c'est
toute la France qui est touchée par
cette situation exceptionnelle madame
monsieur bonjour la France transpira
grosse goutte la canicule est prévue au
moins jusqu'au 15 août l'Assistance
publique hôpitaux de Paris débloque des
lits supplémentaires dans ces hôpitaux
parisiens selon le plan d'urgence
décrété vendredi par le ministère de la
Santé tous les établissements ne sont
pas climatisés ce qui occasionne de
nombreux malaises exemple à l'hôpital
Nord de Marseille qui a pourtant
l'habitude de gérer les fortes chaleurs
reportage Francis Mazoyer et Benoît
Jourdan la climatisation
est en panne depuis un mois à la
maternité de l'hôpital Nord alors tous
les moyens sont bons pour se rafraîchir
c'est très très chaud dans les chambres
il y a pas d'air et la nuit est très
très infernale en fait en plus que bon
le bébé pleure
il fait chaud donc on n'arrive pas à
dormir et c'est fatiguant
les rations d'eau ont été doublées pour
éviter au moment de se déshydrater car
ici la température n'est pas descendue
depuis longtemps en dessous des 32°c le
remède se limite pour l'instant à ces
quelques ventilateurs installés dans la
nurserie seulement deux nouveaux nés ont
été vraiment perturbés par la chaleur
qui n'étaient qui n'avaient qu'un
allaitement au sein puisque les mamans
ne voulaient pas donner de biberon et
ses bébés là ont effectivement eu un
début de déshydratation
de l'eau dans un biberon bien évidemment
un geste répété plusieurs fois par jour
ce bébé semble apprécier la chaleur est
devenue de plus en plus difficile à
supporter pour lui et pour sa maman
se déshabille mais même toutes les deux
parce qu'il fait très chaud et du coup
la panne de ses pyjamas
au lieu de passer le gain sur les fesses
et touche la mémoire dans l'eau
directement
parce qu'il fait très chaud c'est la
réfléchir rafraîchir l'air de la
maternité c'est évidemment l'objectif du
personnel médical une nouvelle méthode
plutôt artisanale va d'ailleurs être
testée des bacs de glace vont être
disposés près des ventilateurs le
confort de bébé n'en sera qu'amélioré
il y a un numéro vert a été mis en place
par le gouvernement pour connaître
toutes les mesures de prévention afin de
lutter contre les effets de la canicule
il s'agit du 0 800 240 250 ce soir face
à l'ampleur de la situation le Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre Raffarin a demandé
au préfet d'Île-de-France de déclencher
le plan blanc il s'agit d'un plan
d'urgence mise en œuvre en cas
d'épidémie de catastrophe ou d'attentat
on envoie le détail et on commence avec
vous docteur juste après c'est
Marie-Pierre courtelmont qui nous
l'expliquent déclenché par le préfet du
département coordonné par le SAMU le
plan blanc concerne les hôpitaux un
point essentiel la réquisition des lits
et des personnels de santé ils peuvent
être rappelés de vacances ou transférer
d'un service à l'autre en Île-de-France
cela concerne 90 000 agents répartis
dans 39 hôpitaux et groupes hospitaliers
les admissions programmées et non
urgentes sont différés les blocs
opératoires libérés leur programme
allégés les victimes ne sont plus
forcément admises directement
produisent des urgences enfin important
par les temps qui courent les hôpitaux
peuvent mettre en service des chambres
mortuaires provisoires pour les
personnes décédées dispositifs d'urgence
le plan blanc est déclenché en cas
d'épidémie de catastrophes d'attentats
nucléaires radiologique biologique ou
chimique ça après deux semaines de
canicule Jean-Pierre Raffarin répond aux
critiques le Premier ministre en
vacances à Combloux en Haute-Savoie est
intervenue publiquement hier pour
rejeter la polémique lancée depuis
quelques jours sur l'action de son
gouvernement refusant les prises de
position partisane il explique que ces
ministres restent mobilisés dans cette
situation exceptionnelle Christelle
Marty
rompant avec la tranquillité de ses
vacances à Combloux Jean-Pierre Raffarin
s'est décidé hier à se lancer lui aussi
dans la bataille contre la chaleur le
Premier ministre a annoncé que des lits
supplémentaires seront mises en place
dans des hôpitaux militaires pour faire
face à la flux de malades critiquer ces
derniers jours sur son manque de
réaction face à la canicule il refuse
toute polémique je crois que la bataille
contre la et ses effets particulièrement
nocifs d'abord sur les personnes mais
aussi pour notre vie économique et notre
vie sociale exige une attitude de
dignité et c'est pour ça que l'esprit
partisan me paraît ne pas avoir sa place
dans cette mobilisation nationale contre
les effets de la chaleur
délits supplémentaires une décision
largement attendue par les services
hospitaliers en surchaud les hôpitaux
regorgent de malades souffrant de
déshydratation et d'hyperthermie et non
pas toujours de la place pour tout le
monde plus grave la vague de chaleur
aurait déjà fait plus d'une centaine de
victimes en France hier la Croix-Rouge a
lancé un dispositif d'urgence pour venir
en aide aux personnel hospitaliers et
aux pompiers des mesures qui pourraient
être amplifiées dans la perspective du
long week-end du 15 août en France les
chiffres tombent ils sont lourds 2500 à
3000 personnes serait morte de la
canicule une situation jamais vue en
France pour soulager les hôpitaux
toujours engorgés Jean-Pierre Raffarin
décide d’étendre le plan blanc à
l'ensemble du territoire voyons comment
cela se traduit dans les faits avec ce
reportage d'Isabelle Dupont Emmanuel
hindinger à l'hôpital Saint-Louis à
Paris
au service réanimation de saint Louis
quatre personnes sont hospitalisées
victimes de la canicule en tout
l’hôpital accueilli une trentaine de
malades en état d'hyperthermie ici comme
dans beaucoup d'établissements on a
anticipé le déclenchement du plan blanc
des lits supplémentaires ont été
rouverts depuis plusieurs jours nous
sommes apte à prendre plus de patients
en charge pour hyperthermie en
particulier ce qui veut dire plus de
présence de personnes médicales et
paramédicales plus de facilité pour
prendre un patient
qu'il n'attendait pas donc nous permet
de libérer un lit et en prendre un
nouveau on différend des admissions non
urgence en mobilisant tous ces moyens
l'eau débloqué 15
litres qui ne reste pas vide très
longtemps cet après-midi c'est l'hôpital
Saint-Antoine qui recherchait des lits
pour victime de canicule
mais complètement d'accord pour cette
hier soir nous leur avons encore
accueilli six patients à hospitalisés et
aujourd'hui on va donc en prendre 10 et
là après on sera pour un moment très en
limite dès nos possibilités d'accueil
l'hôpital n'a pas eu à rappeler le
personnel si on congés médecins et
infirmières ont fait des heures sup les
différents services de l'hôpital se sont
entraidés ce week-end le personnel
théoriquement de repos sera d'astreinte
pour le personnel ils ont été informés
de l'existence de ce plan blanc et ils
doivent se rendre disponibles entre
guillemets au téléphone au cas où il y
aura des choses supplémentaires que nous
ne redoutons pas on est en fin de
l'épidémie de canicules et de et de coup
de chaleur
grâce au déblocage de moyens et à une
météo plus favorable les médecins
espèrent un week-end plus calme que ces
jours derniers
les critiques sont vives de la part de
l'opposition elle considère la réaction
du gouvernement bien trop tardive
notamment la décision du Premier
ministre de déclencher le plan blanc le
Parti socialiste annonce qu'il demandera
l'ouverture d'une enquête parlementaire
à la rentrée et les Verts réclament la
démission du ministre de la Santé
Nicolas Louiset
c'est un retour à Matignon anticipé en
pleine crise sanitaire après 14 jours de
canicule et peut-être jusqu'à 3000 morts
dans le pays Jean-Pierre Raffarin vient
décourter ses vacances pour présider une
réunion dans l'urgence attaquer sur sa
gestion de la crise le Premier ministre
ne change pas d'attitude il se refuse à
tout commentaire
s'il vous plaît les Français ont
l'impression qu'il y a eu du retard à
l'allumage car la crise se déplace
maintenant sur le plan politique alors
Jean-Pierre Raffarin se tient à l'écart
et laisse son ministre de la Santé face
aux critiques
la formule qui est la plus nous avons
réagi dès qu'il fallait le faire je n'ai
en conscience aucun reproche et aucun
regret car nous avons véritablement agit
chaque fois qu'il le fallait et le plus
vite possible mais pour l'opposition
c'est bien le gouvernement et tout
particulièrement Jean-François Mattei
qui ont failli en agissant trop
tardivement les Verts réclament ce soir
la démission du ministre de la Santé
monsieur Mattéi à l'évidence porte une
part de responsabilité terrible dans ce
drame humain et je crois que lorsqu'on a
failli à sa tâche et qu'il y a des
milliers de morts et bien par simple
respect pour les familles des victimes
on remet sa démission et le Parti
socialiste dénonce également un manque
de réactivité du gouvernement qui avait
été alerté par les médecins urgentistes
depuis plusieurs jours voire même depuis
plusieurs semaines et on avait proposé
qu'un numéro vert c'était insuffisant et
on connaît maintenant
les conséquences de la canicule pour
l'heure Jean-Pierre Raffarin rejette
toute polémique mais le PS n'entend pas
en rester là il demandera dès la rentrée
la mise en place d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire avant de
recevoir Jean-François Mattei nous
faisons un retour sur ces 15 derniers
jours du samedi 2 août premier jour
annoncé de la canicule jusqu'à la
constatation de l'épidémie ce sont vos
propres mots monsieur le ministre c'est
un reportage de Martin gouesse pour cet
après-midi plein soleil et ses quelques
cumulus
de la canicule température et
sélectualité du jour température qui
grimpe pendant plus de 10 jours les
températures ne baissent pas et le
thermomètre bat des records une vague de
chaleur jamais vue depuis 1947
rapidement les pompiers les urgences
sont débordés les urgentistes tirent le
signal d'alarme
délicatement je suis désolé mais j'ai
beaucoup de ce qui m'a
fait entre 35 heures et Vacances Le
personnellement que les personnes âgées
sont les premières victimes de la météo
le 11 août les hôpitaux de Paris
reconnaissent que la situation est
exceptionnelle nous avons à faire face à
un flux
continuité
de le dire maudit je le redis
aujourd'hui avec force c'est de libérer
le maximum de lit dans nos hôpitaux le
12 on compterait plus de 100 morts dû à
la chaleur dont 50 pour la seule
Île-de-France un dispositif d'urgence
est mis en place par la Croix Rouge
depuis hier le gouvernement reconnaît
qu'il y a plus de morts que la normale
et par le d'une véritable épidémie voilà
monsieur bonjour le président Chirac est
donc sorti de son silence de retour de
ses vacances au Canada il a un présidé
ce matin le Conseil des ministres de
rentrée à l'issue duquel il s'est
adressé aux Français dans une allocution
télévisée que nous vous proposons dans
son intervention le chef de l'État
demande que toutes les conséquences
soient tirées de la crise provoquée par
la canicule on écoute le chef de l'État
je viens de présider le conseil des
ministres
les membres du gouvernement concerné
ont rendu compte des mesures prises sous
l'autorité du Premier ministre
face à la canicule exceptionnelle qui a
frappé nos concitoyens et notre pays
des drames humains
ont vécu les Français
sont une épreuve que partage
naturellement toute la nation
et tout sera fait pour remédier aux
insuffisances que nous avons constaté
dans notre organisation sanitaire
la canicule la touche les Françaises et
les Français
dans leur santé
et dans leur vie quotidienne
elle a fait un nombre important de
victimes
et c'est à chacune de ces victimes
que je pense d'abord naturellement
j'exprime à leur famille
et à leurs proches
ma profonde solidarité et celle de la
nation
je veux également rendre hommage à
toutes celles et à tous ceux
professionnels et bénévoles qui se sont
mobilisés dans cette période si
difficile
en particulier dans les services
d'urgence
dans les hôpitaux dans les maisons de
retraite dans les grandes associations
et tout particulièrement à la Croix
Rouge
ils se sont engagés avec une compétence
un dévouement une humanité qui force
l'admiration
et à toutes et à tous
j'exprime la reconnaissance des Français
et de la France
aujourd'hui le temps est au
recueillement
à la solidarité
et à l'action
j'ai demandé au gouvernement que les
causes des drames que nous venons de
vivre
soit analyser en profondeur et dans la
plus totale transparence
toutes les conséquences devront en être
tirées afin de prévenir le retour de
telle situation
pour éviter ces drames à l'avenir
notre système de prévention de vigilance
et d'alerte sera revu afin d'assurer une
plus grande efficacité on connaît
désormais les chiffres officiels de la
surmortalité durant les 15 premiers
jours d'août qu'il témoigne de l'ampleur
de la catastrophe
11435 personnes n'ont pas survécu à la
canicule se décompte n'était là ce que
provisoire l'augmentation du nombre de
décès provoqués par la vague de chaleur
et proche des estimations des pompes
funèbres un désastre sanitaire humain se
fierté
11435 décès supplémentaires pour les 15
premiers jours d'août après deux
semaines de bataille de chiffres plus de
contestations possibles ni
d'approximation ce chiffre a été calculé
d'une manière extrêmement précise ce
n'est pas une estimation c'est
aujourd'hui un chiffrage tout à fait
précis des décès liés à la chaleur entre
le premier ou et le 15 août pas de
déclaration du ministre de la Santé
Justin communiqué pour annoncer
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
Jean-François Mattei précise ses données
sont provisoires mais le devoir de
vérité me conduit à les rendre
immédiatement publiques seule réaction
officielle celle du Premier ministre cet
après-midi terrible épreuve pour le pays
pour aussi le gouvernement cette
canicule nous nous rappelle nos devoirs
de d'attention nos devoirs de solidarité
11435 morts de plus le bilan est loin
d'être définitif un Mario catastrophe
prédit par les pompes funèbres générales
depuis le 21 août
devrait tout à fait confirmer les
chiffres que nous avions avancés à
savoir de l'ordre de 13000 à 14000 décès
sur la période du mois d'août et
l'estimation est plus que plausible pour
les urgentistes dépassés par les cathons
ils avaient été les premiers à alerter
les pouvoirs publics ne faut pas
s'arrêter à simplement cette évaluation
chiffrée et elle doit conduire à une
véritable rénovation de notre tissu
sanitaire et social elle doit conduire à
cette enquête parlementaire pour
comprendre pourquoi et comment on en est
arrivé là pourquoi comment les
directeurs de maisons de retraite
s'interrogent aussi la moitié des
victimes de la canicule étaient des
pensionnaires de leurs établissements
11400 morts c'est un c'est un drame
national c'est 4 fois le World Trade
Center cela montre que case à 20 ans
d'indifférence 15 à 20 ans d'absence de
politiques en faveur des personnes âgées
fragiliser tu es tu massivement dans
trois semaines on connaîtra à l'ampleur
exacte de ce drame la bataille politique
elle n'attendra pas elle a déjà commencé
je vous propose à présent de revenir sur
ces dernières semaines cruciales ou les
estimations et les annonces ont été
floues contradictoires et incertaine le
gouvernement se situe souvent en dessous
de la réalité la gestion politique de ce
drame sanitaire a démontré pour certains
une faiblesse Alexandre Cara en ce
dimanche 10 août la canicule fait déjà
des morts mais pas encore la une des
journaux c'est Patrick Pelloux le patron
des urgentistes qui le premier dénonce
une situation qui se dégrade rapidement
les chiffres j'en suis sûr parce que
c'est des gens qui sont sur le terrain
c'est pas des gens qui sont sur un
bureau avenue de Ségur avec une salle
climatisée qui se rendent pas compte de
ce qui se passe dans les jours qui
suivent le gouvernement prend conscience
de la catastrophe pour tenter de
désamorcer la crise Jean-François Matéi
se rend sur le terrain et déclenche le
plan blanc
Jean-Pierre Raffarin ses vacances pour
une réunion d'urgence mais pour
l'instant il ne parle pas
les Français ont l'impression qu'il y a
eu du retard à l'allumage ces
Jean-François Mattei et Hubert Falco qui
sont chargés d'affronter la presse
officiellement le gouvernement maîtrise
la situation mais pour l'instant aucun
chiffre n'est donné le surlendemain pour
la première fois le ministre de la Santé
donne une fourchette officielle
les chiffres qui montent étaient
communiqués par mes services aujourd'hui
100e à la fourchette d'estimation entre
1600 et 3000 en l'espace d'une nuit la
situation a déjà nettement évolué on a
évoqué hier le chiffre de cette de 5000
c'est une hypothèse s'éplosible mais ça
n'est qu'une hypothèse ce jour-là mise
en cause par Jean-François Mattei Lucien
ABENAIM directeur général de la Santé
démissionne deux jours plus tard nouveau
rebondissements les pompes funèbres
générales donnent une estimation de plus
de 13000 morts supplémentaires sur le
mois d'août deux experts sont nommés par
Matignon et par le ministère de la Santé
pour faire un vrai bilan le 21 le
Conseil des Ministres de la rentrée se
transforme en réunion de crise Jacques
Chirac sort de son silence et demande
que toute la lumière soit faite et
pourtant si l'on en croit l'état civil
le gouvernement connaîtrait alors déjà
les chiffres
l'état actuellement effectivement ne
communique peut-être insuffisamment sur
le chiffre que nous nous leur avons fait
remonter et que nous Méry nous avons
fait remonter ils le connaissent très
certainement premier estimation
officielle aujourd'hui un chiffre qui
s'arrête au 15 août mais ce bilan n'est
que provisoire
et en effet le bilan global de la
surmortalité durant la canicule devrait
être nettement plus important c'est ce
que dans ce directeur de l'Institut
national de veille sanitaire le nombre
de victimes continuera d'augmenter car
les personnes âgées dans un état de
grande fragilité ont du mal à surmonter
les suites des fortes chaleurs dans les
hôpitaux on s'attend à nouveau décès
reportage de l'hôpital Saint Michel à
Paris Maryse Borgetto et Marie-Pierre
cassinat un décompte prévisible pour le
personnel soignant de cet hôpital les
chiffres annoncés ce matin par le
ministère de la santé ne sont pas
étonnants
où sont encore en mémoire les
difficultés de prise en charge des
patients pendant la canicule c'est un
chiffre auquel on s'attendait dans la
première quinzaine du mois d'août
effectivement on a constaté une
surmortalité dans le service du
notamment à des hyperthermies au plus
fort de la vague de chaleur une
cinquantaine de patients a été
hospitalisée dans ce service 4 sont
décédés mais les effets de la canicule
vont encore se faire ressentir beaucoup
de personnes âgées sont ressorties
extrêmement diminués par ces fortes
chaleurs et certaines ne s'en remettront
pas
ces personnes âgées polypathologiques
vont continuer à décompenser parce que
ils ont leur organisme a été épuisée par
cette longue période de canicule c'est
tout à fait possible qui est encore une
surmortalité assez importante dans les
semaines à venir le personnel se prépare
donc à accueillir de nouveaux patients
dans ce service une dizaine de malades a
déjà été admises alors que les
températures étaient revenues à la
normale deux semaines après ces fortes
chaleurs des personnes âgées continues
d'en mourir il faudra donc certainement
encore attendre octobre ou novembre pour
avoir un bilan complet de la
surmortalité liée à la canicule
[Musique]